I don't think that that doesn't provide
any evidence into trafficking he was
just talking about how he strong arms
and manipulates women into like working
with him
well yeah what you just said is coercive
uh traffic strong arming somebody into
working with you that that's the
trafficking part that's the strong Army
just to be clear like I said
I said some good things about him and
putting it mildly when you go there's
some things I don't like about him
because what he just said is he's
admitting to several crimes and I know
that's trafficking maybe is not
sometimes as obvious as people think but
he did describe what trafficking is I
don't think anyone should look up to
that part of him at all for sure that's
that's definitely validate the good part
you can pick things from people and you
can take the good things and leave the
bad
um he's Jack and does karate